i on va faire juste un petit jeu je vous
demande d'imiter elle est où là et les
oubliés ou la bonne idée là je vais
prendre des personnalités je vais
d'abord désigner une personne jean
michel mr attention vous allez devoir
imiter marquer mais sa soeur chantal
ladesou à au moins coûteux alors votre
[Rires]
attention
bernard montiel on va voir qui est le
meilleur imitateur bernard montiel faut
me limiter les doigts s'ils merci frère
mes petits chéris c'est bon tu y es
l'attention et eric naulleau eric
d'avoir invités nikos à salue les loups
ne sait pas faire
22 truc n'importe quoi là tout de suite
on va recevoir aman aman ouvrage
[Rires]
d'accord et naulleau il élimine
croissance et vous le meilleur attention
mes mamies isabelle morini-bosc jane
birkin
oh là là j'ai mon frère m'a dit il faut
que 13 de chaque pays qui est le sentait
le chien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle sait pas toutefois pour tous
attention à gâteaux pour agathe vous
allez devoir limiter aux noms très dur
véronique sanson adhésion totale à tous
oui ce point ça alors ça va petit petit
couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l antisémitisme
c'est pas mal mais isabelle respecté
label récente des tensions castaldi
julien lepers d'une tout de suite à un
indice aussi j'ai dit attention
non ça va être dur jean luc reichmann
c'est sur la question
la question c'est bien
d'où la question à laquelle
wojtak dark badaboum choisissant une
attention ce qui est un domaine vous
n'êtes pas bon départ et mon imitation
nicolas sarkozy à houla écoutez chers
français j'ai quelque chose à vous dire
frérot zilina soit la sarkozie on est
amis du poil à gratter pas limité moi je
sais pas je vais vous le dire je vous le
dire franchement j'ai pas vous le dire
une fois c'est pas vous tire toi fois je
vais pas vous le dire trois fois comme
chabot est venu gentil mon pouvoir enfin
duel ta gueule pour l'instant c'est
isabelle attention à eux dalida dalida
pour le club
ah ouais mais c'est toi là-bas dans le
noir il va choisir au fello lentilles et
dj c'est toi là-bas dans le noir ouais
pas mal avec isabelle vous êtes la
grande maison de limitation c'est bien
vous allez donc refaire deux invitations
dans un an
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]